so who's gonna win the war of words
let's bring in media guru and pollster
Frank Luntz okay Frank can the Democrats
successfully kind of wiggle out of this
given kind of the polls that they've
leaned on that shows the growing support
among the young for socialism and some
of the ever more radical leftist
positions of their prime candidates what
do they do here
half of all Democrats say they would
vote for a socialist and this is work
that we've done in the last eight weeks
what you have right now is a battle but
it should not be a battle between
socialism and capitalism it should be a
battle between socialism and economic
freedom and that's what I hear the
Republicans starting to say because in
the end socialism meets government
control government interference all the
things Americans don't want but one
warning Laura young people are moving
further and further to the left and
Republicans are going to need a message
to to attract them if they are to be
successful all right well let's get to a
word that we've been hearing a lot of
lately watch despite your dignity the
values of human dignity the sense of
dignity good for you dignity good for
you and we did not talk about this
before dignity and that's just a couple
of times they're about ten times they
mention that long and they're all doing
that so clearly someone's advising more
than one candidate at the same time but
you know why because what they're trying
to say is respect if government doesn't
respect you then the only way that they
can get around that is by using the word
dignity raising human dignity it's a
word that goes back to the 1960s it was
first used it for European socialism I
do think it's gonna play well here when
they say dignity however I think you
hear the Republicans and more
conservatives come back and say hmm
because a lot of the most undignified
people in the let's say the
entertainment elites have said the most
horrific things they criticize Trump for
being coarse but what they've done is
like beheaded images of Trump the most
disgusting images of Melania and Trump
hasn't even gone there yet I mean he's
hasn't gone too well really dignity
dignity is this is this is this
dignified or infanticide is that
dignified but they're using dignity as a
way to support their Gov
intervention to them dignity is welfare
dignity is food stamps dignity is more
government providing more services to
people that's how the Republicans say
for us dignity is the right to determine
your own destiny without government
interference dignity is freedom the the
ability to make your own decisions
yourselves now Frank I want you to
listen to another phrase I think the
Dems are hanging on watch health care in
my view is a human right health care is
a basic human right we should give
everyone in this country health care is
a basic human right for free health care
is not just a human right it should be
an American right good for you I'm
coming for your job front you know
you're not gonna need me anymore because
those videos are so good and this one
60% of Americans agree and the numbers
are increasing over time my concern is
that the Democrats are now using late
sometimes
language of the right as a way to push
policies of the left and conservatives
have to be careful about that you use
softer gentler kinder words to push
things that are about either government
control or government giveaways and the
Conservatives need to have a message and
need to have an answer to that because
when something is a human right I think
Charles Murray remember maybe it was a
Victor Davis Hanson when something is a
human right you don't have to debate it
anymore so if it's a human right there's
no debate you have to give it to them
and you must be cruel or inhuman
deserves a certain level of health care
a certain level of income correct and
you just use the phrase everyone
deserves and I've been criticized about
this because I know the conservative
that things aren't a right life liberty
the pursuit of happiness
those are god-given rights but these
other things are not so I came up with a
language you deserve and I had people on
the right saying Frank don't do this
it's not right
interesting okay finally here's the
message I think that Trump and his
supporters and some of his surrogates
will be pumping out our goal is peace
and prosperity not war and destruction
I'm very excited about new possibilities
for peace and prosperity
and prosperity good for him interesting
because we Republicans haven't really
been on the peace side have they no
right I swear that you've been following
me because I had a meeting over at the
State Department today where I was
talking about their word peace why are
we not promoting it and and Trump is
doing it but it's only just started
peace and prosperity our priority is
number one and number two for the
American people if that's his theme then
he's he's headed in the right direction
we're talking about this the other day
but liberals used to believe in peace
they were like the peace sign make you
know make love not war
now Trump's like I don't want to mate I
don't want to make so much war and want
more friends around the world and like
how could you pout out of these people
but liberals also believed in freedom if
you go back to the cross who Stills and
Nash songs freedom is always on the left
right now freedom is on the right and
control so control versus freedom
liberty responsibility these are we're
gonna be unpacking this throughout the
whole election cycle it's gonna be fun
let's remember economic freedom not
capitalism that's key for those on the
right fantastic Frank thanks so much